we saw this happen in Japan in the 1990s
where they did not act boldly and
swiftly enough and as a consequence they
suffered what was called the Lost Decade
Jack it wasn't that long ago that many
people in the United States were
absolutely terrified that Japan was
going to overtake America as the largest
economy on the planet when the Japanese
stock market hit an all-time high in
December 1989 even comedians like Andrew
Dice Clay were freaking out over the
land of the ever rising Sun can we drop
two bombs on them a couple of years ago
what was in those bombs fertilizer but
of course we know now that Japan didn't
become the world's largest economy in
fact in the early 1990s Japan went into
a prolonged economic slumber from which
it's yet to fully awaken Japan's economy
hit the skids for three basic reasons
and they're all sound familiar
that's Anthony Randazzo a policy analyst
at reason foundation the nonprofit
behind recent TV he's the co-author of a
recent study and Reason magazine cover
story on Japan's Lost Decade
first was an overly aggressive financial
sector that didn't believe that their
games would ever come down they became
euphoric with all the money they were
making and became unwise in their
investments the second was monetary
policy they kept interest rates low
flooded the market with money and
encouraged the rise of an asset bubble
the third was a collection of government
policies such as regulatory policy and
tax structures that encourage an
unnatural rise in the price of assets
leading into their bubble the parallels
between the u.s. and Japan don't end
with the causes of unsustainable
economic bubbles though the official
responses have been eerily similar as
well the first was they lent money to
struggling financial institutions the
second was they propped up the so-called
zombie businesses with bailouts
companies that without government
support were just gone out of business
and third was they spent the equivalent
of 1.4 trillion dollars in stimulus
projects over seven years
but none of that worked in Japan the net
result public debt skyrocketed as a
percentage of gross domestic product and
the unemployment rate doubled which is
way too close to what we're seeing in
the u.s. now so what should the Japanese
government have done in the 90s and what
should the US government be doing right
now there are some important things we
can take away from the Japanese lost
decade we need to lower taxes for
everyone keep them low this will give
people more of their own hard-earned
money and it will encourage business
activity leading to economic growth we
need to stop excessive government
spending that is increasing our national
deficit and our national debt and we
need to let zombie businesses really go
bankrupt this will lead to some
short-term economic pain but the upside
is is long-term sustainable economic
growth for all sectors of the American
economy as we clear the way for better
business and investment opportunities as
the President and Congress plow ahead
with more spending more regulation more
debt and more taxes here's hoping they
look to Japan's recent past for guidance
on what not to do if they don't they
just might be creating an American boss
decade for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie